[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
encourager la prise de parole être
investis d'une mission et ça va écouter
voici en quoi j'espère que notre échange
qui ne s'arrêtera pas là sera aux
platines
on partira du postulat aussi ce soir que
nous sommes toutes et tous des sachant
cela sera l'objet de mon passage
comprendre et être à l écoute auprès de
vous cette génération z au moment où
nous parlons
une génération critique
ce que je vous propose ce soir ceux de
vous présenter mon expérience en tant
que professionnels de l'image et des
mots de vous faire découvrir des profils
des mécanismes de pensée qui vous seront
utiles pour devenir des citoyens
éclairés
le changement climatique la hausse du
niveau des océans la fonte des glaces
les médias les politiques votre
entourage on ne cesse vous abreuver des
conséquences demain de nos actions
passées
c'est le fondement même du message
présenté par ban ki moon en 2008 on
parle parfois du solent climatique comme
s'il ne concernait que la planète et non
ceux qui l'habitent
des propos remplis de tolérance mais
aussi d'un espoir
et d'un réveil et d'un éveil nécessaire
comment dès lors faire insulter ce vent
de changement
accompagné l'éducation et la
compréhension de ce nouveau monde qui se
dessine face à nous
c'est là que se présentent les réseaux
sociaux comme étant une alternative
vers une meilleure communication
auprès d'un public cible vous cette
génération z en soif de changement
et c'est là que se présente justement
des profils comme la chanteuse viso ou
encore l'humoriste seles d'arber des
noms
des visages des personnalités engagées
régulièrement la société nos bombarde
d'image de corps parfait d'une recherche
constante vers un cul de la perfection
imposer la normalité et cette normalité
elle prend la forme d'un personnage aux
cheveux lisses
à la pour
soyeuse et surtout aux cheveux bruns
et cette normalité qui est imposé à ce
jour
elle est aussi a expliqué par une
société qui friande de
buzz mais surtout et avant tout
d'une normalité qui s'impose devant nous
j'en reviens du coup sûr le principe de
mon passage auprès de vous ce soir c'est
vraiment vous parler en fait d'une
problématique qu'on a régulièrement
notamment à travers les réseaux sociaux
qui se présente comme étant en fait des
porte parole à la fin de ces
influenceurs aussi vite que le vent je
voulais vous présenter vous parler
notamment du différents profils ici vous
avez du coup ces lignes agace isogood
qui parle régulièrement de
problématiques en lien pour une
consommation et pour un mode de voyage
beaucoup plus respectueux de la planète
en gros la thématique du moment des
carbonique et à côté vous avez au reine
alia sera qu'un qui parle régulièrement
de sujets encore compliquée à
appréhender pour cette société actuelle
je pense notamment au féminisme à
l'hyper sensibilité
ou encore cette part importante
de nos besoins respectifs
à l'origine de cette crise écologique
je voulais vous présenter aussi
une campagne que vous voyez qui m'a
beaucoup touché est impactée ici c'est
la mac intel solidaire qui a pu poser
pour le magazine cosmopolitan en 2018
vous l'aurez compris comme beaucoup
l'ont eue ici au moment de cette
publication nombreuses ont été les
réactions négatives mais aussi à
linverse nombreuses ont été les
réactions de soutien
et de prise de parole de cette
génération que vous êtes une génération
qui ne peut plus se taire et une
génération qui ne veut plus se laisser
faire
c'est sur quoi j'ai pu constater
notamment dans le cadre des cours que
j'enseigne autour des relations presse
que la génération que vous formez
actuellement est une génération engagée
mais aussi une génération qui demande à
l'autre génération tout simplement son
droit en droit de connaître cette
période des trente glorieuses mais à
l'ère du digital une génération qui
demande aussi cette opportunité de se
réaliser que cela passe par an quatre
professionnels ou aussi par la chance
d'avoir les mêmes conditions de réussite
que nos générations précédentes vous
l'aurez compris nos parents ou grands
parents
et aussi pour faire toujours office est
référencée court que j'enseigne
régulièrement j'ai pu constater que les
étudiants quand je leur demande à quelle
heure phrase de let motiv la première
chose qu on me répond
je ne sais pas je les aimais pourquoi du
coup à quel moment à moi 25 ans j'avais
des envies des aspirations des passions
pour vous dire j'ai 31 ans et je suis
toujours fan des mangas voilà mais aussi
fan de cuisine
je me verrais bien plus tard pourquoi
pas avoir mon compte tik tok aussi faire
des vidéos sur des chats et j'en passe
voilà apparemment ça cartonne mais aussi
là où je voulais en venir c'est que
quand je demande cette phrase au
leitmotiv aux étudiants s'est pour une
raison simple cette phrase de let motiv
elle résume pour mme en quelques
secondes l'énergie d'une personne ce
qu'elle donnera à la vie et surtout ceux
qui la fera vivre et
la mienne à l'image de la thématique de
ce soir pour rappel la quête
1 reprend cette citation de winston
churchill selon laquelle la chance
n'existe pas ce que vous appelez la
chance c'est l'attention aux détails bon
vous l'aurez compris le détail ce soir
j'ai buggé deux fois autant vous dire
qu'on coupera mai
c'est justement cette recherche de cette
perfection que je m'impose
personnellement et cette quête aussi
d'écouter et d'entendre cette génération
que vous êtes qui recherchent d'autres
modèles une génération qui est en droit
aussi de se réaliser c'est ce qui fait
que régulièrement je m'impose aussi
cette notion d' écoute que nos anciens
et nos anciennes n'ont pas cette notion
d' écoutes qui implique notamment le
fait que vous aussi avec votre prise de
parole et que vous aussi avec de
nouveaux moyens est de nouveau mise en
communication tic toc twitter twitch ou
encore youtube et c'est grâce à ces
médias qui sont multiples mais aussi les
messages multiples vous permettent aussi
de vous exprimer en face d'une
génération qui des fois est totalement
décorrélé de la réalité
et
je rajouterai aussi le fait que les
réseaux sociaux
sont en froid de plus en plus à une ixic
nécessaire comme cela il car dans
l'alimentaire avec de nombreux labels
notamment récemment un nouveau label a
fait surface pour la communication
auprès des influenceurs et auprès de
cette génération que vous êtes un label
rse
encore un label de plus comme le label
big or pour mesurer en soit il n'apporte
rien de nouveau en revanche il impose
aux communicants
de parler vrai et ils imposent aux
communicants de vous écouter
à en vous prenant comme socle de mon
discours je vous ai présenté mon
expérience personnelle
une expérience que vous l'aurez compris
est faite de hauts de bas mais surtout
une envie profonde de réaliser mes
propres rêves et surtout de faire de ses
rêves une réalité
alors mon expérience débutant en 2009
quand j'ai quitté mes racines quand j'ai
quitté mes origines quand j'ai quitté ma
chérie le papillon la guadeloupe
à la gemmi 19 ans j'ai décidé de quitter
le nid familial
désireux d'écrire mon histoire
désireux
de de construire mon aventure
mais surtout quand je vous le disais
faire de mes rêves une réalité
et cette envie s'est concrétisé en
devenant attaché de presse mais aussi
avant tout comme j'aime à le dire un
communicant qui met au coeur
l'écoutent que ce soit auprès des
journalistes de mes clients et aussi
des personnes que je vais informer
à travers les articles
un adage que j'applique régulièrement
dans mon travail
et que j'ai à coeur de le répéter ici
devant vous m'informez
avant d'informer
pourquoi et en quoi c'est important
parce qu en informant
et en me nourrissant du monde qui nous
entoure j'ai pu comprendre que ce monde
capitaliste et l'industrie nous enferme
dans notre part les plus profondes il
nous renvoie à nos origines
à combien ici ont pu avoir un rejet en
voyant la mannequin tu es solide est
posé pour le magazine cosmopolitan en
2018 alors je ne vous blâme pas on a été
longtemps et du king et surtout on
trouve hockey de considérer des corps
filiforme comme parfait
et ceci ça s'explique avant tout par
justement des réseaux sociaux qui nous
bombardent des images
de corps parfait d'une recherche d'un
culte de la perfection imposer la
normalité
à 6 en écoutant ce soir un sentiment de
colère s'empare de vous je vous
demanderais d'en faire une force
notamment contre cet adage qui nous
attend tous
subir violon de la communication
une image prix défini faisant des
influenceurs des porte-parole aussi vite
que le vent aussi vite que le vent c'est
la deuxième fois que je le répète durant
ce théâtre ce soir et pour moi cela
résume bien
la problématique que nous avons avec les
réseaux sociaux
trouver un sentiment de kate mais
surtout pouvoir parler à toutes et tous
qui est d'ici qui écoutaient ce ted mais
aussi qu'ils écoutaient ces influenceurs
que vous connaissez que vous suivez dont
vous êtes abonné et ces influenceurs
avant tout sur nos plus en plus nombreux
justement à partager des messages
d'acceptation de tolérance
mais aussi avant tout un message où vous
êtes de plus en plus écoutez donc
vraiment c'est l'objet de mon t'aide à
travers les réseaux sociaux c'est
vraiment de vous montrer que
un réseau social comme instagram peut
être intéressant pour justement
réalisée se réaliser et aussi avant tout
être en porte parole pour toute une
génération
c'est exactement ce que j'ai pu faire
avec mon travail attaché de presse en
faisant notamment cet
accomplissement je dirais en étant
devant vous ce soir autant donner en
toute honnêteté je voulais et faire un
teddy que ça l'a jamais 35 ans j'en ai
31 g4 en avance je sais je suis jeune si
les jeunes antillais
mais c'est vrai par contre vous voyez
que oui en toute honnêteté j'ai buggé au
tout début et j'ai repensé en fait avant
tout à cet échange que j'ai
régulièrement avec les influences ans
que je connais et les journalistes et je
suis arrivé à la conclusion que le
discours que j'ai pris deux semaines à
écrire et au moins une semaine à
apprendre
au final la plus la puce la plus
important des choses que je dois mettre
en place et me mettre moi en avant mais
surtout
m cette envie que j'ai de partager
régulièrement avec les étudiants quand
j'enseigne stater faire parler mon coeur
et c'est justement je pense
cette envie profonde que j'ai que
j'espère que vous pouvez plus ou moins
palper avec mes mots mes yeux moi que
vous pourrez découvrir notamment un peu
plus après notre échange sur comment
communiquer comment aussi c'était très
intéressant si nécessaire comment
insuffler ce vent de changement pour
faire en sorte que les réseaux sociaux
deviennent vraiment en fait
une tribune pour vous et une tribune en
fait qui vous sera utile pour être
entendus et écoutés
je terminerai aussi mon passage par le
fait qu'il est nécessaire de définir une
problématique à travers tout ce que je
viens de dire et cette problématique on
doit y apporter une solution
et cette solution c'est vous
car précédemment je parlais du
changement climatique la fonte des
glaces la hausse du niveau des océans on
broie du noir mais par contre vous êtes
la solution face à ces inégalités
vous êtes la solution face à ces
changements climatiques et vous êtes la
solution face à ces grands qui dirige
est d'ailleurs ce qu'il fallait retenir
qu'une chose en plus
ce sens fait d'eux
de mon passage aussi c'est que à travers
les réseaux sociaux
vous pouvez avoir
cette prise de parole en l'obtenant en
surtout je dirais avant tout
à travers un accomplissement personnel
c'est à dire que bien évidemment si vous
avez envie d'avoir un compte qui parle
de sujets engagés comme le féminisme ou
l'hypersensibilité précédemment avec
orane cas vous pouvez aussi parler des
sujets qui vous passionne et c'est cette
passion quand je vous disais que la
phrase de let motiv qui manquent de nos
jours en fait à cette génération que
vous êtes et pour développer cette
génération enfin cette parade ont cette
envie c'est ses hobbies il est important
aussi c'est ce que j'ai compris à
travers mon expérience
de se réaliser personnellement
alors oui
bien évidemment
on applaudit sans ce soir ce que je vous
demanderais d'abord c'est de penser à
vous
cette place légitime que vous avez dans
la société
être entendu
et être écouté
merci
[Applaudissements]